Aaron Carter we lost a Disney family
member I know the family runs tight here
sending our love out to the family
definitely crossed
across the times within the
knees out to Nick
such a tragedy and I think we really do
need to get the world in order so that
we can start focusing on Mental Health
it's a real thing we need to stop losing
our youth to it and maybe one day people
will get the hint and it's a part of
just our everyday life to have checkups
mentally and help our society out we are
obviously not thriving right now
oh
what's up
who are you
I'm Santa Claus this is a big deal right
tell me the Nostalgia for you being here
around this series did you watch The
Originals were you fans where are our
hearts at right now we feeling the
holidays tell me
I'm gonna be a hundred with you we are
here because of me and because the Santa
Claus is still my favorite movie to this
day I can't even say it was like oh when
I was a kid I am 35 and fully obsessed I
literally like that is Santa he's right
there yeah I mirror all of those things
but you not so much you ain't feeling
our Santa Vibes huh
yeah Santa's real right he is right next
to you listen I love a good story I
thought the first one was absolutely
amazing and it brought me joy for sure
however I'm more of like just bring me
cake
instead of movie I'm like bring me cake
slash The Nightmare Before Christmas
slash The Nightmare Before Christmas my
dog's name is zero after the dog and I
remember that's why we like you that's
why we came to you first I'm listening
y'all we're celebrating together this
year what are we doing you said bring me
the cake what's your tradition what's
your favorite thing for the holidays
what do you can't wait to get your hands
on or dive into it
um purple sweet potato pie she makes the
most amazing purple sweet potato pie and
she also makes a cranberry sauce to die
for so that's what I'm hoping for oh
yeah and family and family
yeah
no potatoes yeah you got it it's amazing
you can't even concentrate right now
check out the YouTube channel that's on
there no it's not oh it's not I like it
it's
down there somewhere
[Music]